In lesson 9, we learn that a mutation of the BRCA1
or 2 gene can significantly increase your risk for breast cancer.
>> Until recently, a company called Myriad Genetics held patents
for three of the most prevalent mutations in the BRCA1
and 2 genes. Allowing them to dominate the gene diagnostic
test market. Actually, charging thousands of dollars for an individual test.
>> However, in June of 2013, the
United States Supreme Court ruled against them.
Saying that you can't patent a naturally occurring DNA sequence. Now this will
open up the market for many other companies to start doing this test.
>> Now the Supreme Court decision was unanimous.
Although they still allow you to patent synthetic
DNA sequence. But what we want to know from
you is, do you agree with this decision?
Do you think that companies like Myriad Genetics
should be able to patent naturally occurring genes
found in individual humans? Check yes or no, and then tell us why in the box.